foreign
lawyer from a powerful legal Dynasty in
South Carolina
his family firm was founded more than
100 years ago it's well known wealthy
and influential in its corner of the
state
Alec Murdoch raised two sons with his
wife Maggie they were embedded in
Southern High Society a picture of
Happiness until one night the night of
the 7th of June 2021.
[Music]
thank you
at kennels on the Family Estate Alec
Murdock is alleged to have murdered his
wife Maggie and youngest son Paul he
denies it did you take this gun or any
gun like it
and blow your son's brains out on June
7th or any day or anytime
no I did not
[Music]
it was Murdock who made the emergency
did they shoot themselves oh no hell no
okay and are they breathing no ma'am
got a whiskey Fox whiskey mic both
gunshot wounds to the Head law
enforcement officers who turned up to
the scene found Maggie Murdock shot five
times with an automatic weapon Paul had
been shot twice with a shotgun
prosecutor say Alec Murdock used
different weapons to make it look like
an ambush
I would just let you know because of the
scene I do I did go get a gun and bring
it down here it's in your vehicle you
have any guns on you at all leaning up
against the side of my car you're fine
man you're fine
[Music]
Alec Murdoch's Alibi was that he hadn't
seen the murdered pair for 90 minutes
before finding them dead he would later
admit that was a lie a lie exposed by a
Snapchat video filmed by his son Paul
just minutes before he was shot quick
cash in the background of the video you
can hear Paul's father say the words
come here Bubba
quit
it places Alec Murdock at the murder
scene around the material time
[Music]
the prosecution case is that Alec
Murdock killed his wife and son as a
distraction shame on you he'd been
stealing Millions from the family farm
and from clients prosecutors say that he
killed family members to elicit sympathy
and to slow down or to Halt
investigations into his financial fraud
[Music]
the Modoc family have been in the
headlines before not for good reason in
February 2019 Mallory Beach a 19 year
old girl was killed after being thrown
from the Murdoch's boat when it crashed
into a bridge at the wheel that night
was Paul Murdock he was drunk he's the
Murdoch's son who years later would be
shot dead
[Music]
I don't know new questions surrounding
the Modoc family and other dark
mysterious events police are looking
once more into the death in 2015 of a
classmate of the oldest Murdoch son
they're also looking into the death of
Gloria Satterfield
she was the Murdoch housekeeper who died
after falling on steps at the Murdoch
home at the time it was deemed to have
been an accident
in small towns South Carolina they're
looking closely at the Murdock family
its power and its past